this bad weather isn't stopping Lucy
from carrying out his work today he's on
a special mission in the center of
Shanghai we're speaking out against
ignorance and discrimination against
people who are hiv-positive Lucy and the
other activists walk through the city in
small groups it's a way of spreading
their message that avoids drawing the
attention of the authorities always
sensitive when it comes to
demonstrations the group go to several
locations across the city it's a
strategy that's not without risks their
presence on the streets might escape
official scrutiny but the photos they
post online could also attract attention
lose she works for the organization
Beijing gender he writes information
brochures about living with HIV and
gives talks in schools Lou is 24 years
old and was diagnosed with HIV for years
ago fighter league when I found out
about my infection I stayed completely
calm I simply decided that I didn't want
to live anymore and I planned all of the
details of my suicide but a friend held
him back from carrying out his plan and
after that Lou decided to share his
experience educating others about living
with HIV has become his vocation hong
kong's war there are difficulties
everywhere at work in life those who are
infected lose their jobs and are evicted
from their apartments some doctors even
refused to treat them there's
discrimination in many areas of life she
should I feel good
it's problems like these that the
Chinese HIV activists want to bring to
the attention of people in Shanghai it's
desperately needed both Chinese society
and the Chinese government have a little
understanding of how to deal with people
who are hiv-positive that makes the work
of people like new shoe all the more
important but means they tread a narrow
line between bringing attention to their
cause and drawing unwanted attention
from the authorities